Nils Wanderer ist einer der
vielversprechendsten
deutschen Klassiksänger
– und einer der jüngsten.
Scheiße, voll verkackt den zweiten Teil!
Noch mal.
Was fasziniert einen 23-Jährigen
an jahrhundertealter Musik?
Klassische Musik ist überhaupt
nicht stehen geblieben,
weil wir als Interpreten natürlich
immer uns darum bemühen,
es so gut wie möglich zu interpretieren,
so neu wie möglich zu gestalten
und trotzdem die Wurzeln
nicht zu verlieren.
Und ich finde es ist
einfach eine Form von …
von Wissenschaft mit Seele,
die mich unglaublich fasziniert.
Das Teatro Massimo in Palermo
ist das größte Theater Italiens.
Nils Wanderer tritt hier als
Gastsolist in die Fußstapfen
von Stars wie Luciano Pavarotti.
Als Countertenor singt er in einer Tonlage,
die meist nur Frauen erreichen.
Wenn das die Stimmbänder sind
– und die schwingen bei ’ner
normalen Männerstimme so –,
benutz‘ ich nur die
Randkanten der Stimme.
Das ist dann ’ne Mischung … Mischung
aus dem Gedächtnis …
des muskulären Gedächtnisses,
das ich als Knabe noch hatte
– diese Knabenstimme, im
Männerkörper ausgebildet.
Nils Wanderer studiert noch Gesang,
hat aber schon große internationale
Musikwettbewerbe gewonnen
und leitet selbst einen Knabenchor.
Sein Professor ist für die letzte Probe
vor der Premiere der Johannespassion
nach Palermo gekommen.
Für ihn ist Nils Wanderer
ein Ausnahmetalent.
Also, zuallererst muss man sagen, dass es
’ne besonders schön timbrierte Stimme ist.
Also, schönes Timbre heißt viel Farbe;
’ne Stimme ist nicht nur metallisch
und nicht nur auf den Punkt
und kommt nicht nur übers Orchester,
sondern ist halt ’ne …
’ne wunderbare Farbe.
Man könnte es vielleicht mit ’nem guten
Rotwein vergleichen, so ’n bisschen samtig.
Ich würde drei sehr trockene
Besen verspeisen,
wenn das nicht ’ne
unglaubliche Karriere wird.
Er kommt aus einem kleinen
Ort in Süddeutschland.
Inzwischen singt er viel im Ausland.
Manchmal bekommt er Besuch
von Familie und Freunden.
Mit fünf wurde Nils Wanderer bei
einem Casting im Knabenchor entdeckt.
Seine Eltern haben mit Musik
oder Theater nichts zu tun,
aber sie haben ihn immer unterstützt.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich so lebe, wie
ich lebe, meine Familie so ist, wie sie ist.
Meine Eltern, die geben
mir die Bodenständigkeit,
meine Wurzeln, meine Heimat,
mal durchzuatmen,
auch über andere Dinge nachzudenken.
Und das ist mir sehr wichtig.
Drei, zwei, eins … Palermo!
Die Selfies landen auf Instagram.
Nils Wanderer ist nicht nur Sänger,
sondern auch Choreograph und
entwickelt neue Projekte.
Darüber postet er
ganz selbstverständlich.
Alte Musik und neue Medien
– für ihn kein Widerspruch.
Fertig machen für die Premiere der
Johannespassion von Bach.
Der Solo-Auftritt ist einer der
wichtigsten seiner Karriere.
Mein Traum ist es, als
Opernsänger erfolgreich zu sein,
mich im Bereich Regie fortzubilden,
als Regisseur zu arbeiten,
als Choreograph zu arbeiten, später mal
vielleicht als Professor zu unterrichten
an ’ner Hochschule und …
aber immer Sänger zu bleiben.
Das ist, was ich bin, was ich lebe,
was ich sein möchte: Darsteller.
Er singt über die Kreuzigung und
Wiederauferstehung Jesu Christi.
Kommendes Jahr wird er bei der
Johannespassion in Salzburg
nicht nur singen, sondern
auch selbst Regie führen:
der nächste Schritt in seiner Karriere
– und sicher nicht der letzte.